the world needs the next Ironman
stocke chose you he made you an Avenger
this all seems big time I'm just the
friendly neighborhood spider-man Tony
saw something in you
he believed in you
the world needs you how's the CERN
little tight around your web shooter
Parker okay
- there's monsters coming out of the
ground everywhere we go I need a suit
suit
I've got this let's go save the world
spider-man
on the costume looks great for the
costume party she knows I told her I
figured it out get gifts Parker the
world needs that I would love to team up
with help I would really like to be
spider-man hope we had a really really
cool little sequence that was gonna be
there which was just basically mark and
I'm messing around on set and then they
might be shoot this and it actually be
quite cool but yeah I think hopes my
favorite character I think he's so funny
and so I would really like to see the
ruts in the in the MCU right now we know
time is fast
all right my phone stops ringing okay
you stop right there
no time is five so Peter Parker when he
comes back to this universe he it's like
he blinked and five minutes online so
it's a really kind of interesting things
trying to deal with yeah and we had a
lot of fun with John Watson they the
producers to Sonia mob and they're
trying to figure out how they were their
kind of tackle that crazy concept
I don't think is that actually any
function mister why it's red and black
one of the cool new functions which is
great for me is that the new web shoots
is that in built into the suit so I
don't have to wear those bracelets
anyway because those bracelets were
break all the time and and then they get
stuck and you couldn't take them off and
then kind of annoying so in the new suit
the web shooters are actually built into
the suit which is really great and then
the stealth suit is a really really cool
cool piece of art and it's basically
given to him by Nick Fury there's a
really really funny scene of how I get
the suit it's really funny and it's
awesome albeit at times not the best but
Nick Fury
in this film is recruiting spider-man to
come and fight these elemental creatures
at the worst time possible the
spider-man and Peter Parker is exhausted
and he needs to just take a break from
this huge responsibility
and so the relationship between Cody's -
between Peeta and Nick Fury is a little
rocky and they're not friends and they
butt heads quite a bit so it was quite
nice for me to get to play a different
sign of do Parker because he kind of
gets on with everyone and yeah I'm just
really excited to see you know how Nick
Fury and Peter Parker kind of come
across the world it's interesting
because he in the first film he was
equally trying to become an Avenger and
this film he's evilly trying to kind of
not be an Avenger you know he's he's a
16 year old kid and he wants to go on
his school trip with his friends to
Europe and experience life as a normal
teenager
but unfortunately being spider-man for
him is a responsibility he just can't
shape so this film is all about him
realizing that with the loss of Iron Man
the world needs someone to step up and
fill the shoes and whether that
Spiderman or not he needs to be the one
to step up and make a difference in the
world and quite these elemental
creatures that have come through this
dimensional rift snapping to save the
world so so he deal youth brief in his
own way and I think I deal with grief
and loss in a similar way where I kind
of keep myself busy and I don't allow
myself times or anything about it that's
why he's been on this vacation hi
everyone its Charlie we have a bunch of
new spider-man far from home footage to
breakdown and Tom Holland explaining a
bunch of key things about the movie
what's going on with the new spider-man
suits
what's going on with Avengers end game
and Thanos snapping a rift in reality
allowing quote-unquote Elemental
creatures to get out even though I think
a little bit of that is just to keep up
appearances for what the Mysterio
storyline is actually going to be during
the movie but we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos it's just getting started they
just started the spider-man far from
home press tour so it's gonna continue
like this for the next month until the
movie actually comes out we're doing a
new round of the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video we'll just break
this down top ten style because there's
so much stuff and I cut
down that comic-con panel that he did
answering questions and details about
the movie a little bit just a really
important stuff
so starting with number 10 the brand-new
footage more of him with the stealth
suit in Nick Fury talking about the
stealth suit Tom Holland actually said
that the scene where Nick Fury gives in
the stealth suit and him trying to put
it on for the first time winds up being
a very funny moment during the film they
turn it into a big scene so it's not
just that Nick Fury is recruiting him to
do all this James Bond work solving the
problem of these elemental quote-unquote
creatures with Mysterio but they also
play a lot on the comedy of him getting
a lot of these cool new things before
the film gets really crazy towards the
end he also says it's a lot of funny
moments between Ned leads and MJ's
character because once she finds out
they have this little contest between
the two of them to try and see who is
the best
spider-man friend number nine he talks
about how they addressed the characters
being snapped by Thanos during Avengers
infinity war and then being brought back
by the Hulk's Infinity Gauntlet snapped
during Avengers endgame they do address
it during the movie and he says from
spider-man's perspective he just blinked
in five years went by in an instant but
he is aware of the passage of time and
they do deal with it during the film
number eight there was also a separate
clip of him recently talking about fan
OSes snap being the one to open the
dimensional rift allowing the elemental
creatures to come through but like I
said I think a little bit of that story
isn't totally true and they're just
making that up to keep up appearances
for what Mysterio's arc is going to be
during the film misleading Peter and
Peter learning the truth about what's
really going on but there was a big
question after Avengers endgame when
they started talking about the
multiverse we got that mysterio
multiverse scene where he explains this
is the 6-1-6 universe in the MCU where
we were just wondering which snap it was
that tore the whole like what are they
gonna say is gonna be Ironman snap when
he got rid of Thanos or just gonna be
Thanos his snap when he erased half of
all life in the universe now we know at
least within the lies that they're
telling about the movie that they're
blaming Thanos for that which I think
makes more sense you pinned that on
Thanos rather than pinning it on Iron
Man there's other good side effects for
Iron Man's Avengers endgame snapped that
I'll talk about what I do more Marvel
phase four Fantastic Four x-men videos
number seven he talks about spider-man
dealing with his grief over the death of
iron man that is a big arc during the
film like he says somebody
to step up and fill irons man's shoes he
even comes right out and says it whether
or not that winds up being me
spider-man's character talking about
himself remains to be seen but I think
that's part of the idea of the film is
that he steps up and he doesn't become
the Next Iron Man he becomes the best
spider-man he can be he probably
eventually realizes that Iron Man didn't
want spider-man to turn into another
Iron Man he just wanted him to become
the best version of himself
number six Tom Hall had also talked a
lot about Tobey Maguire in Andrew
Garfield's versions of spider-man and
how they inspired him I just think it's
funny that he goes back and talks about
them every once in a while because we've
been talking about bringing them back
for Sony's spider-man into the spider
burst franchise the animated movies we
don't know exactly how long Tom Holland
is gonna be playing the spider-man
character hopefully for a long long more
time but I do think that before he's
done they are gonna try and get all of
them into some kind of movie even if
it's not a live-action MCU movie they
could always wind up doing some live
action elements in the animated
spider-man into the spider burst movies
number five he briefly addressed the
spider-man MJ romance storyline and
talked about some of the funny moments
that they have with Ned Leeds and Betty
Brandt's high school romance some of
their scenes are meant to be funny in a
cringy way like very over-the-top funny
but the way he describes his
relationship with MJ is that it's kind
of like puppy love and people have been
wondering who this character is ever
since we got the first trailer well it
turns out that he's actually an original
character he's not somebody from the
comics and he's meant to be a romantic
rival to Peter for MJ's affections even
though she's not completely impressed by
him but it's just like a really small
subplot during the movie it's not a
really huge deal but that's basically
what this character is therefore number
four he talks about the differences
between Tony Stark Iron Man being a
mentor in Nick Fury as a mentor to him
this Nick Fury's relationship is very
strained at the beginning but I think
part of the idea is is they have a
similar arc that Iron Man in Nick Fury
had in the early Iron Man movies
remember the Iron Man two post-credit
scene where he gets all upset when Nick
Fury tells him he's way too
self-centered to be part of the Avengers
initiative textbook narcissism
agreed okay here it is a recruitment
assessment for Avenger initiative
Ironman yes I got to think about it read
on Tony Stark not not recommended that
slowly over the course of the next
couple of vengers films Nick Fury starts
to respect him more and more as this
really great figurehead so I think
that's the same idea with his
relationship of spider-man through these
films number three he talks about the
new suits and it sounds like he doesn't
totally remember why exactly they went
with the Steve Ditko colors because
someone asked him why is the suit red
and black does it do any special new
stuff he does say that the brand new web
shooters are actually built into the
suit so they're not using those black
wristbands on the original stark tech
suit anymore
like remember when he holds this
hologram up in the trailer it's probably
something to do with that and you could
almost look at it as a bit of a nod to
the Tobey Maguire organic web shooters
but it's still a mechanical web-shooters
he has like he still doesn't generate
the web himself number two he also talks
about teaming up with a Hulk in a future
film I don't know if they'd ever
actually do that but Mark Ruffalo still
does have one movie on his Marvel
Cinematic Universe contract so he will
be back at some point during Marvel
phase four even if he does have some
kind of secret cameo and spider-man far
from home which I don't think that he
does that wouldn't count against that
one movie that he has to fulfill on his
contract so it just has to be like a
really big appearance like Thor Ragnarok
but he does talk about a very funny
Avengers end game deleted scene that he
had with the Hulk but I think it had
something to do with the funeral scene
and because that was meant to be a
really serious moment I can understand
why they would cut out any really extra
funny stuff that they would tag on to
that just because it's meant to be so
somber and you end with that hamburgers
flying oh I'll get you all the
hamburgers you want kid your father
loved hamburgers there was another
Avengers end game deleted scene video
that I was gonna do recently so I'll
just address that again when I post that
other video but number one within that
same breath he was also asked about
crossing over with Wolverine and
Deadpool but the way he reacted and make
this sound like he has some ideas of his
own but Kevin Feige hasn't officially
told him any of their real plans for
x-men during Marvel phase four or Marvel
phase five so there's still wide open to
speculation but like I said the
spider-man far from home press tour is
just starting now they're gonna be doing
this all month long so we're probably
gonna be getting a whole bunch more cool
details about Marvel phase 4 and the
spider-man movies the future of
spider-man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so if Tom Hall and spoiler man
drops any really cool details I will
totally include it in the videos that I
do but there will be a couple more big
trailers that they'll drop before the
movie comes so leave all your video
requests in the comments below
while you wait for everything click here
for that really cool Iron Man scene
during the other big spider-man far from
home trailer and click here for my
non-spoilery x-men Dark Phoenix review
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight
[Music]